Parmi vos recherches, vous avez découvert des plumes de dinosaures, justement ?
On a eu, effectivement, la chance de trouver des plumes de dinosaures à 2 ou 3 reprises
En Charente ?
En Charente, oui, en Charente-Maritime, près de La Rochelle.
On a trouvé dans un premier temps des morceaux d’ambre, de la résine de conifères fossilisée.
Dans cette résine, il y avait à la fois beaucoup d’insectes fossiles,
que ce soit des moustiques, des mouches ou des guêpes.
Et puis dans un morceau, il y avait 7 minuscules plumes millimétriques.
Alors ces plumes millimétriques, évidemment,
étaient filamenteuses plus que plates, comme des plumes modernes.
Elles avaient un rôle qui n’était pas un rôle de vol,
trop petites pour jouer un rôle dans le vol,
plutôt liées, cette fois, à la régulation thermique.
L’ambre qui contient les plumes a été découvert en 1999.
Les plumes ont été découvertes dans cet ambre là l’année qui suivait, donc en 2000.
C’étaient des plumes accrochées à un dinosaure ?
Les plumes que l’on a trouvées, il n’y avait pas de dinosaure avec dans le morceau d’ambre, on aurait bien aimé
mais ces petites plumes, puisqu’elles étaient millimétriques
étaient l’équivalent d’un duvet sur la peau d’un dinosaure au Crétacé,
il y a environ 100 millions d’années.
Cela veut dire que vous, paléontologue,
vous travaillez parfois avec des ornithologues ?
Cela nous arrive parce que, évidemment,
nos compétences de paléontologues ne nous permettent pas forcément
de comprendre toute l’anatomie détaillée que peut porter,
en terme de plume, un oiseau et a fortiori un oiseau disparu.
Donc en discutant avec un ornithologue,
on peut comprendre où se trouvaient, sur le corps de l’animal autrefois,
les petites plumes que l'on a trouvé.
Est-ce qu’elles étaient sur le ventre ?
Est-ce qu’elles étaient sur la queue ?
Est-ce qu’elles étaient sur la tête ?
Quel rôle elles pouvaient avoir dans la vie de l’animal ?
Est-ce qu’elles servaient à voler ?
Est-ce qu’elles servaient à l’isoler, on va dire, thermiquement de la température extérieure ?
Et c’est comme ça, que l’on est arrivé à la conclusion que de toutes petites plumes,
un petit peu molles et filamenteuses,
ça ne pouvait pas servir à voler.
C’est essentiellement un duvet qui servait à la régulation thermique du corps,
un peu comme les poils chez les mammifères.
Alors vous, vous êtes paléontologue et vous cherchez des dinosaures
et vous avez aussi trouvé des plumes ?
Alors effectivement, outre les plumes découvertes dans l’ambre,
en Charente au début des années 2000,
également en Charente mais dans des niveaux de type argile,
dans des dépôts argileux, on a trouvé une plume.
Il faut dire que ces fossiles de plumes sont extrêmement rares,
ce sont des fossiles que l’on ne trouve pas tous les jours.
Et on a trouvé cette plume qui mesure environ 25 millimètres de long,
qui elle, a une structure très très proche de certaines plumes d'oiseau actuel.
Ce n’est pas une plume qui est spécialisée pour le vol,
puisqu’elle présente une symétrie.
Mais elle est vraiment typique avec les petites barbules symétriques,
de part et d’autre de l’axe central.
Elle date de quelle époque ?
Celle-ci date d’environ 100 millions d’années,
un tout petit peu plus récente que celle découverte dans l’ambre, 99-100 millions d’années.
Et qu’est-ce qu’elle nous apprend sur l’animal qui la portait ?
Malheureusement, on a des plumes, à la fois,
chez les dinosaures non aviens et chez les oiseaux.
Donc, les dinosaures non aviens sont ceux qui n’ont rien à voir avec les oiseaux ?
Voilà, ou ceux qui sont proches des oiseaux
mais qui ne sont pas encore des oiseaux.
Alors, cette plume n’est pas assez caractéristique
et sur une plume isolée comme celle-ci,
à cette époque-là, le candidat potentiel,
qui a perdu cette plume, pouvait être soit un dinosaure
qui n’était pas encore un oiseau soit déjà un oiseau.
Surtout que dans ces gisements en Charente,
dans des couches très très proches de ces niveaux argileux,
on a trouvé des petites dents d’un dinosaure très très proche des oiseaux
qui, lui aussi, était certainement recouvert de plumes.